I'm gonna Nelson and this is build your
squad all right so my first pick name is
the foundation of the team with the
quarterbacks Erin's not up there so it
makes a little difficult that's been the
easy number one pick
you see far another Packer since we're
here at Super Bowl 50 for chief 49ers
let's go whether they're calling to
Montana Bowl right you know since you
played for both grew up watching Joe
when he came over and played with the
Chiefs Oh put Joe Montana out there
there weren't any backs easy for me some
guy who can do it all another kanzen a
lot of people don't realize it but
another Kansas you gotta go is very
standard grew up in Wichita Kansas I
grew up in Kansas a we got to stick
together as a receivers man this is
gonna this is tough
we'll stick with receivers we'll leave
to tight end out it will go with Jerry
Rice kind of a given it's got all the
numbers did it for years and years and
years so we'll put him up there and you
got to keep the chemistry going you
don't want to mess up the chemistry I
know a lot of touchy I had a lot of
chemistry with my co-director you got to
keep the chemistry DB's i loved-ed read
just a playmaker all over the place can
do it all leader on the team play with
incredible defense and so on
we'll go read you like to get after the
quarterback put another get a packer guy
in there I know he's in the Eagles
uniform but kind of change the fact
organization
put it back on the map with the Super
Bowl with him and Brett coming in so
there you go there's my squad I don't
think you can argue with it I wish to
talk about the quarterback was difficult
obviously these guys are all great
winners productive everything I were
throwing 12 in there for my for my sake
running backs is easy for me just to
bury the class catchers it's tough I
mean you got Randy who had a long career
and did it in multiple spots and did it
at an elite level especially early on
too and then came back with New England
Tony Gonzalez is probably one of the
most steady guys out there so that was
tough not to not to pick him but you got
to go with I to go with the receiver so
and the DB rose dion is the guy but I
want to go with the safety for that and
all the play making heat is but dealing
with a shock of that dion play receiver
and DV and return fight so price is done
that could get more out of one guy and
then Reggie was a given so we'll go with
that one all right so this is my spot
right here we got Joe Montana strolling
through this guy Jerry Rice who's gonna
be open all the time because we're
worried about Barry Sanders running the
ball and then we have the stoppers on
defense the guy getting after the
quarterback and the guy picking up all
the passes though this is my swatch and
behalf the michelob ultra pure gold the
organic beer changing regular farms in
into organic farm